lo que quiere hacer en este vídeo es una
justificación razonablemente rápida de
la idea de que el valor absoluto de a
menos b es igual al valor absoluto de b
- a para cualquier par de números a y b
antes de comenzar a analizar esto quiero
comenzar con una proposición más
sencilla la idea de que yo tengo un
número cualquiera x y el valor absoluto
de esto que bueno estoy usando x porque
ya use a y b el valor absoluto de x va a
ser igual al valor absoluto de menos x
para analizar esto vamos a dibujar una
recta numérica
la dibujamos aquí
este es cero
y hay una circunstancia en la que x es
positiva obviamente si x es igual a cero
pues ambas van a ser igual a cero y esto
se cumpliría pero si aquí tenemos una x
positiva la x negativa va a estar a la
misma distancia de cero que la x
positiva así que aquí estará menos x o x
negativa y el valor absoluto de x va a
ser esta distancia de 0 a x y el valor
absoluto de menos x va a ser esta
distancia de 0 a x negativa es la misma
distancia pero hacia la izquierda por lo
que estas dos cosas van a ser
equivalentes ahora si x fuera negativa
vamos a dibujar esto si x fuera negativa
si esto fuera x que será menos x va a
ser lo que tenga x pero negativo por lo
que será la misma distancia pero a la
derecha de 0 yo sé que esto suena un
poco raro el estar poniendo aquí una x
negativa
aquí está x podría ser un -2 y si x es
menos 2 - x va a ser menos menos 2 por
lo que va a ser un valor positivo va a
ser un 2 de cualquier manera vemos que
el valor absoluto de estas dos cosas es
el mismo esta distancia es el valor
absoluto de x y esta distancia en este
caso es el valor absoluto de menos x
espero que a ustedes les parezca
correcto esto que les acabo de explicar
que estas dos cosas son equivalentes
ahora sí estamos de acuerdo en esto
vamos a analizar esto podemos comenzar
con el valor absoluto de a menos b y hay
muchas maneras en la que podemos
analizar esto podemos reescribir no sé
si es positiva o negativa ésta podría
ser un número negativo pero podemos
reescribir esto como menos a negativa
menos b
analicemos esto un poco y vamos a
asegurarnos de que nos sentimos cómodos
con este análisis con esto que acabo de
hacer aquí esta es exactamente lo mismo
que tener menos a negativa - menos a el
negativo de un negativo va a ser
positivo y esta es una positiva no he
cambiado nada aquí y esto a que va a ser
igual pues podemos factorizar nuestro
signo negativo vamos a factorizar esto y
lo voy a poner en un color diferente y
esto va a ser igual al valor absoluto de
factor hizo los negativos aquí pongo ese
menos y aquí abro paréntesis escribo
menos y como factor hice el menos aquí
pues me va a quedar una vez positiva
esto es más b cerramos el paréntesis y
porque es interesante esto pues ya
dijimos que el valor absoluto de un
número negativo es igual al valor
absoluto de ese número positivo el valor
absoluto de menos
- jamás va a ser igual al valor absoluto
de esto sin el signo negativo vemos aquí
que el valor absoluto de esta x negativa
es igual al valor absoluto de la x
positiva por lo que el valor absoluto de
menos a negativa más b es lo mismo que
el valor absoluto de a negativa más b
y negativa más ve es lo mismo que tener
ve - solamente estoy cambiando el orden
aquí ve - y con esto terminamos acabamos
de mostrar que el valor absoluto de a
menos b es lo mismo que el valor
absoluto de b - a y espero que con esto
ustedes tengan la confianza de saber que
esto es correcto pueden probarlo con
muchos números si quieren dibujarlos
sobre una recta numérica encontrar la
distancia entre estos números en la
recta numérica y comprobar que esta
fórmula funciona aquí solamente factor
izamos un signo negativo reconocimos
esta propiedad de aquí arriba para
llegar a esta conclusión